the prophet Muhammad s. wasallam told us
whoever builds a mosque for Allah Allah
will build for him a similar house in
jenah and we know the great reward that
will not only be gained but rather will
fill your grave after your death
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives shahada in the Masid
whenever someone learns something in the
Masid yes that will be something that
you will have on your scale
[Music]
people don't know that you know low key
I mean people will know that actually
you were quite a famous rapper weren't
you for some time well if you're a
rapper I think the only thing I can do
now is we have to have a freestyle I
mean let me tell you something the first
time I ever met zishan the first thing
we ever did together as non rappers we
freestyle against each other freestyle
what was it called a freestyle uh battle
rap so you want to put on the on the
tracks brother yeah DJ khed over here
this is prepared silent we got a little
instrumental we'll start with low key of
course you know
okay uhhuh yes
now
okay some people call him lowkey I call
him off key no key Ry Ry Roy
let let me start again I only have one
more chance yeah okay let me think about
it okay
think some people call him lowkey I call
him offy lowy Ry bro ke I'm the alpha a
b c d e f g h i j k l o p q r s t u v WX
y
z why why why do you want to fight me
hey
Lefty take the knee take
knee take the knee Lefty take the knee
for me
all right your turn your turn okay okay
yeah yeah
mhm
okay yeah check it on the mic straight
murderous I don't know you probably
think I'm D I don't
know sorry sorry yeah good it's not good
yeah listen don't know why you stay
thissing bro it's not an issue listen
when it comes to the facts I'm more than
ready you must think I'm pierc Morgan
already on telly but it's not that type
of party ooh give me the bars they can't
harm me oh anytime on the beat you know
we rip it and we can I want to send a
big up to Zan cuz it's him that does all
of the editing bro you better go back to
wrestling okay put put on for for round
two
yeah you guys are crazy if things get
physical they want to go pen yeah P
Morgan condemn and I will condemn your
bars energy energy yeah
yeah let me see let me um let me start
again that one
that again yeah have I got a good flow
get there there get
somewh okay let me think
about if things get physical don't want
to go pen yeah when you went on PE
Morgan condemn and I'll condemn I will
condemn energy energy expend I don't
need to
expend back come back come back come
okay
you bro yeah you asked to battle me I
said whatever you think Best But to be
honest it's a cringe Fest it's
like when it comes down I got to give
something newest to be honest I feel
sorry for the
viewers I'm I'm I'm impressed by the
fact that you can get these things
like
that thank you so much thank you enjoyed
it yeah it was very
good big up Zan SM to I think people
will be wanting us to collaborate on a
new
rap hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a Masid a DA Center
establishing a Masid to conve The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the reward
even greater so give generously and
Allah will give you even more